if Jonathan winters is ever accused of
anything he's got the perfect alibi
he was someone else at the time when I
first saw him before the show he was
still trying to decide whether he could
be a drunken Eskimo the queen of the
Vikings or a doorknob
I'd rather take him out simply as
himself to begin with because when he's
Johnny winters
he cannot be imitated the wild wild man
my friend Jonathan winters in my opinion
it's impossible to understand the genius
of the late Robin Williams without first
understanding the corresponding genius
of his idol Jonathan winters winters was
the master of improvisational comedy
from the early days of TV in his
stand-up in various sketch appearances
on talk shows
what he did was never scripted the
characters he invented the scenes he
enacted were plucked from the air in
front of his eyes the kids had some
candy and they said daddy daddy come to
the river there's a bear here and we
won't get some pictures of bear well a
bear ate to get but we got some
wonderful victory one of winters most
famous and simplest bits was called the
stick from the Jack Paar Tonight Show
news up with a stick watch his over to
mr. Hume anything
well I was a pretty good cast winner Bob
Iger on to something this time mm-hmm
I'm sorry Marvin its women I put in the
bloody stocks too long
that's a nice and just up there just
this side of green I sing them Beatles
and this is one of their feelers 37
years later another comedian did a very
similar routine with a pashmina on
inside the Actor's Studio
I came to Bombay last year
tonight we are going to cook octopus
ball
Robin Williams and Jonathan winters were
kindred spirits they work together for
the first time on the TV show Mork &
Mindy winters played his son from which
point they remained great friends until
winters death in 2013 only a year in
change it turns out before Robin
Williams took his own life in this clip
from a 60 Minutes profile on winters its
Robin Williams who expresses the great
lesson that his mentor taught him what
was indeed the great philosophy of both
their comedic lives
Jonathan has just taught me about the
world is open for play
I mean he's that anything and everybody
is mockable in a wonderful way this idea
that the world is open for play is an
extremely rich one it suggests rightly
that humanity and our shared reality is
made up of fluid elements of language
and social structures which are
sometimes codified into rules and
pressures and laws but that even the
most rigid feature of what man makes can
be turned flexible again and malleable
again and funny with play winters and
Williams saw reality for its basic
elements and felt a grand freedom in
their work to rearrange those elements
into hilarious parodies of our world yes
I was so taken with this guy I was when
I first first met him and I'm working
linearly we did we had a harmless those
were good days you had access to more
medication in the
we're Robin Williams exceeded even the
master was in his dramatic scope not
only could he create exaggerations of
character in his comedy but he had the
ability to reproduce the subtleties of
character as well
feeling like God put an angel on earth
just for you I could rescue you from the
depths of hell
and you wouldn't know what it's like to
be her angel to have that love for her
be there forever in the end both talents
reflect the same empathetic observation
of people winters and Williams like no
one else before or since understood the
stereotypes in subtlety and the subtlety
and exaggeration it may seem as if this
sublime energy of play passes away with
them but of course the opposite is true
we have that energy for all time
because they gave it to us no Reverend
Angley my hands are our credit coz you
can tell well just consider them not as
hands anymore but it's paused be ready
to do this gay little cat tree don't be
afraid but yeah yeah yeah don't be
afraid Oh buddy my hands on your head
now no but they're in my hands why would
you put your hand on my head but that
doesn't merit my hey you shot go with me
it's a to shop work with me now work
with me demon spirit Bobby connects look
at my hands they're straight out
straight out nah
now you can hurry Ang's now you can
serve things go table 14 table for you
nobody can't get him back that way how
do you get him back forever
look horrible this is called mime
syndrome a tendency to be in a box for
no reason for horrible long periods
tendency to walk against the wind when
there is no wind won't you please help a
mime is a terrible thing to waste
you heard me say it ma'am here's a turbo
finalized look at this this also means
surrender so so basically gyptian army
training course
okay ready drop gun again one more time
drop gun again drop gun again all this
money